the jurogan experience that dude's been
famous for so long too that like is it's
if you're in a circle yeah i think he's
like one of the best if not the best
ever like well 100 one of the best ever
if you go back and watch bigger and
blacker you know you go back and watch
bring the pain those are [ __ ] classic
specials they're as good as anybody's
ever done those are two absolute rock
solid classic
all-time great stand-up comedy specials
yeah it's crazy undeniably but i liked
it because it was like that was like
when you were saying something
and it was in in the form of jokes
so you're saying these big points
and it's done in the form it's rapid
boom yeah boom yeah boom like that's
what
that's why that's why to me
like it's like he is just it's another
plant like i mean he's pacing the state
yeah like you can see him like even like
he was on letterman when like the
letterman stuff with the women and he
went on letterman and like uh he's like
what are you doing these girls and like
starts yelling like when uh letterman
got in trouble the cheating on his wife
or all that stuff
did he get in trouble right yeah yeah
like a long time ago and chris went on
and chris was a guest and just
talked about it i think it
saved letterman because it was just
being talked about in the open right
right and he went in and i was like
think with with with chris you can see
like he gets like a zone in his eyes
where you can just tell like he's not
even really looking at anybody it's just
like comedy yeah it's coming he's like a
groove he's in the groove of just you
know
an elephant walked in front of him he
would be like i never saw it like it's
just
his eyes are just like you know just
pacing he's really funny again right now
that's what i've heard i saw him at the
store uh before the whole will smith
thing and he was working out his
material he was [ __ ] good man he was
really good like classic chris rock [ __ ]
because you know went through a hard
divorce lost a shitload of money and
it's a lot of pain and so
and then came out of it and then on the
other side of it it's like he's really
good right now
yeah i heard someone uh
someone told me about his hour now that
they heard it's great yeah like
first heard from my friend eddie bravo
he saw him at the store and he texted me
he goes brother this guy is on fire
right now he goes he's so good right now
i go really he goes you got to see him
and then i was there uh like a week
later and i got a chance to watch the
set
it's nice to see it's because you know
there's always that drop-off point with
a lot of like great comics
like they'll uh have a couple really
good specials and then they have one
that's uh
yeah it's not that good yeah you'll have
another one that's not that good and
you're like you're like ooh
i feel like you need to be an underdog
like you want um you almost
like you want to have people doubt you
right and that's the whole beginning of
comedy is you go on stage and this crowd
doubts you so the very your first time
on stage is talking to 20 people that
don't think you can do this right so
every time you go on stage is just
proving something right and then maybe
you get too big to a point to where now
they're there and if you're not aware of
it like they said like that i think you
said like this self
audit or if you're constantly just
reminding yourself that you're not like
he's almost like he's hearing me outside
you like dude i'm nobody i'm an idiot i
don't think i know how to do comedy to
be honest like you think that all you
know like
once you tape an hour you're like i
don't know how i could ever do it ever
again i should quit honestly and get a
regular job and probably is going to
happen like you just this panic yeah of
just all this stuff and so if you don't
have that then you can kind of get lost
and then you're like
and that's when i think specials can get
bad you're just cramming them out and
you're like ah you may do one i'll do it
tomorrow i'll go and you just are
pounding them out and then you need that
back to like and almost like with uh not
saying chris was at that point but like
the resurgence of now he's a true he had
that happen at the oscars
so now
everybody's going to be like expecting
a lot from him
if he comes and does something whatever
it's like i mean it's it's not there's
no payback there's no nothing it's like
oh dude who cares yeah but if he comes
back with this next special and it's
it's it's what it
what i'm hearing it's supposed to be
it's gonna be it's right back where it's
i mean he's at his best oh when i saw
him he was killing i mean killing
and you know it was a drop in set it
wasn't you know it wasn't enough you got
to find that i think you got to find
that motivation yes the motivation that
makes you you know sinbad said that i
remember reading a book and he's talking
about he's like because it's hard to go
you ride he was running greyhound buses
to shows and so sinbad's like laughing
with the bus driver i mean he's just
like the most funny he could be and
you're in limos or something and then
everything kind of changes and you lose
that that hang where you lose that
perspective of like that kind of outside
yeah world and you think like well i
walked to my show and my my coffee
wasn't
where i thought it was going to be and
then and you're like well that's
someone's job you're like
you're like you go well all i do is ask
for that to be right there i don't think
that's crazy am i being crazy saying
that i would like my coffee
right on that stool
when i walked past it you know and you
you don't go what
yeah you don't go get it dude go get
it's across the street there's a
starbucks walk over there and go grab
whatever you want to grab and you're
like but i don't
but people recognize me and stuff you're
like no one's gonna just go over there
and go do your dumb thing and like bring
yourself back to like some kind of
reality yeah to go like all right you
get insulated you get insulated yeah and
when you chris rock how do you not get
insulated everywhere you go everybody
says oh that's rock
you